welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston this is a breakdown of secret
Invasion Episode 3 betrayed and spoiler
warning while this episode seems to
betray Us by killing off Amelia Clark's
character so early and revealing Brody
whose voice that definitely was on the
call as a scroll I don't think
everything is as it seems to be as
always there are so many Clues to break
down so many different conspiracy theory
rabbit holes so let's go through this
episode shot by shot for all the details
you might have missed and by the way new
rockstars is now three channels this
main channel for Easter egg breakdowns a
deep dive for special film analyzes from
me in the break room where you can find
our secret evasion after show inside
Marvel subscribe to all three and
support our network with a scroll
inspired shirt at nerd riot.shop let's
get started the episode opens with the
Scrolls Pagan xerx zoo and Beto prepping
to infiltrate the British royal Navy as
submarine crewmen sunlight streams in
through the window blinds as it does
later in a scene with gravic and Gaia
the blinds visually evoke the shredded
document design of the series official
character posters the truth will always
out but it will always be blocked by
some nefarious forces remember remember
Pagan in the comics is the name of the
scroll who poses as Elektra and gets
killed off by Echo and that body's
autopsy is what exposes the squirrel
invasion xerxu is the name of the 70s
Marvel Premiere Comics characters a
scroll who impersonates Richard Nixon
Pagan tells beta what motivates these
Scrolls he joined the same reason I did
not fear of the past faith
in our future
all faith is built on risk Pagan seems
to be more of a True Believer in this
girl cause than even gravic is graphic
is driven by fear of the past and by his
bitterness over being betrayed it's a
shame that Pagan is essentially a pawn
who gets sacrificed this episode so that
gravity can make a bigger move now the
files that they hand out read Naval
service of Great Britain and Northern
Ireland Northern Ireland being part of
the United Kingdom of course xerxu is
given the identity of Ensign Connor
Combs beta was given Captain Tom Phipps
and Pagan The Lieutenant Commander Dave
Hamilton now Lieutenant Commander
Hamilton is the elder officer who
pressures the other Captain into turning
that launch key later on now normally
these launch keys are only necessary for
icbms I don't think this missile is
nuclear but it is interesting that
whatever the missile is it would be
required a simultaneous turn of two
different officers also interesting to
note that Captain is a higher rank than
Lieutenant Commander in the British Navy
in general I don't know the people who
wrote this episode know the actual
protocol of how any baby officer on a
nuclear submarine would launch a missile
but anyway graphic leads to scroll
Council into this super scroll chamber
including the news pundit Chris Stearns
UK prime minister Pamela Lott NATO
Secretary General Sergio funny and Jack
yukbin whose importance to Human Society
we still don't know he doesn't wear a
suit I'm wondering if he's like an
industry leader of some kind we also see
the Lawtons or the skrulls posing as
these human scientists tinkering with
DNA samples on the wall behind him is a
framed headline scientists makes a new
DNA Discovery and on the dry erase board
we see a bunch of notes about DNA
including the words recomputation
strategy and a timeline of reconfiguring
DNA it's just interesting that the
squirrels needed human scientific
knowledge to lead this genetic
breakthrough of super Scrolls now yes it
could have been Scrolls posing as these
humans making the Breakthrough
themselves but why would they even use
the human forms at all if they were only
ever going to use this research for
scroll purposes and the comics the super
scroll Discovery was made by the scroll
Priests of scientists including Drogi
fenu edu so while graphic writes off
humanity is just murderers and Savages
he needed our science to make himself so
super and graphic finally says the words
here so in the Marvel Comics super
Scrolls was introduced back in 1963's
Fantastic Four number 18 but the
character of clert no time for vowels a
squirrel with the ability to impersonate
the power is it the Fantastic Four in
addition to their appearances the super
scroll Powers so far on this show seem
to be pulling from some of the power
sets of the Fantastic Four stretchiness
flaming on Etc in the comics super
Scrolls ended up heightening things into
a big mess and Brian Michael bennis's
secret of Asian crossover storyline as
most of the Avengers end getting swapped
with super powered super Scrolls pagon
cir Beto infiltrate hm and B Clyde hm
which is a real naval base in Scotland
best known as the home of many of
Britain's nuclear missiles it does
appear to the same one here as both sit
on a river and it's mentioned later but
you can see here on the submarine that
it is named the Neptune Neptune is the
god of the sea in Roman mythology based
on the Greek god of Poseidon one of a
couple nods to Maritime mythology in
this episode Graphics plan is to hijack
as submarine to shoot down a human plane
and Spark a global conflict this is a
common Espionage movie Trope that we see
in the Rogue submarine and Tom Clancy's
The Hunt for Red October as well as the
Russian nuclear submarine that gets
false orders and Mission Impossible
Ghost Protocol would this really lead to
a global nuclear war or something like
that would they just chalk it up to
Terrace or with the Scrolls in the
rankings of these governments and Chris
Stearns on TV the fan the Flames until
this eventually led to a global conflict
we're not really sure but at the end of
the day this is all a fake plot by
gravic to out Gaia but to me that still
doesn't explain why Talos and fury
aren't able to call on this
bogus play okay we flash back to New
York City in 1998 just one year after we
flashed back to Fury enlisting the
Scrolls in 1997 in Brixton and one year
before genetic scientist Maya Henson
which showed Tony Stark her early
research that would later become
extremists which comes back in this
series Fury orders his coffee black
because it's not around also
interesting to note that graphic by
comparison is constantly dumping sugar
in his tea and in his coffee interesting
conflict between these two leaders a man
versus a child Raisin Bran vs Cinnamon
Toast Crunch Fury meets Vara this is the
squirrel who presented graphic to him
and Brixton taking on a new human form
of Priscilla notice that Vara is also
wearing that same six-pronged ring that
her scroll form wore back in episode 2
but no longer wears in the present day
when she's married to Fury Vara is
reading Raymond Carter's A New Path to
the waterfall a collection of poems with
an introduction by Tess Gallagher
Carver's wife whom he married just six
weeks before his death from lung cancer
at age 50. similarly Vara will consider
herself a partner to Furies turn into a
widow in his absence Vara hands Furious
mintel saying this should put Jacob's
men on their heels ah this is a
reference to general drakov leader of
the Russian Red Room Rey winstone's
character in The Black Widow film
drakov's daughter was first mentioned in
Avengers by Loki the Black Widow and was
later revealed to be Antonio drakov AKA
Taskmaster and we see how this intel was
attained by Blood notice a bloody
thumbprint on the envelope actually this
Intel may lead to what was eventually
Natasha's Budapest mission in Black
Widow when she targeted dracot in a
bombing that also disfigured Antonio we
jump to the present as Fury makes
breakfast wearing his glasses now
forgive me for continuing to track this
but fearing alternates in the show when
he does and when he doesn't wear glasses
in scenes and since we know his lenses
have an augmented display that show
infrared perhaps other metrics like a
heart rate I think he wears these
glasses in interactions when he wants to
see if someone is lying like notice how
hard he stares at Cilla here you've been
in touch with graphic while I was gone
and why are you asking me that because I
just need to be sure yes she doesn't
answer the question and I think Fury
registers that Priscilla's human form is
age as a scroll she would be able to
keep herself young if she wanted to but
she chooses to age her human form to
keep up with her husband also I think it
would look weird if Yuri had a young
wife who never ever aged and maybe the
soldiers didn't want to pay for constant
deaging and he has Fury's nickname for
her is Cilla in Greek mythology Cilla
was one of two monsters along with
kryptus in The Odyssey who Mariners
would get caught in between kind of like
the saying between a rock and a hard
place leading us to wonder who would
Fury's corruptus be could it be the
scroll that Vara and Sila introduced to
him graphic could it be Gaia or is there
another silent partner who we have not
met yet I'll get to that theory at the
end of this breakdown but Fury watches
Chris Stearns on the TV who warns about
the rising threat of World War III why
would Fury watch this kind of pundit
well maybe he knows that Stearns is a
scroll from earlier years of recruiting
and he wants to see what kind of
propaganda message graphic is putting
out there Fury says leaving the broken
clocks right twice a day yes one recalls
the clocks on Sonia fallsworth's wall
which represented a spy's death in the
line of duty in the office that we see
Sonia in this episode also clocks in the
background Priscilla Grill's Fury about
turning her into a widow in his absence
which is an interesting choice of words
considering that her first Intel to Fury
back in 1998 was to subvert the Black
Widow Red Room operation also
Priscilla's cookware and her drinking
glasses in this kitchen as is her top
all the color green these Scrolls cannot
help but show off their Verdigris but
Fury turns away from Cilla to let her
take this call I don't have that
information at hand right now yeah Fury
has to know that this call is Shady and
maybe the glasses frames going back
behind the ears put a special microphone
back there some hearing aid action
allowing Fury to hear roady's voice on
this call ascilla walks off Fury stares
intently at her pink flip phone as if he
could be using the scanner in his
glasses lenses to perform a kind of
digital star 69 on the previous call
Farah still uses a Samsung Galaxy Z flip
4. filmmakers like Ryan Johnson have in
the past claim that Apple will not allow
antagonists to use iPhones if they want
to use iPhones as a prop so no iPhone
doesn't automatically need someone as a
villain but based on her Shady lawyer
this episode it could be pointing to her
nefariousness gravit questions guy about
how the cops knew about the safe house
last episode and Gaia blames Brogan gave
it up under torture seems like she
called the cops last episode to kill off
Brogan to make Pagan's position weaker
as Brogan was his recruit Gaia says I'd
lie
I'm a good liar she seems to be testing
graphic here less afraid of him Ernie
tests that he would put her through this
episode why ain't she afraid well this
episode's previously on reminded us that
she followed Pagan into the Super
Squirrel room and saw that machine
activate so I think she has powered
herself up with extremist healing powers
and she is not afraid of calling
Graphics Bluffs she and graphic arrived
in London for Taylor's parley she wears
a green and purple top again scroll
colors there graphic meets Taylor at
London's National Portrait Gallery where
they look at James Guthrie's 1930
painting Statesman of World War One it
depicts Winston Churchill at the center
who wasn't yet prime minister he was the
minister of Munitions during World War
One as well as all the other majority
and minority leaders of Commonwealth the
UK Australia Canada New Zealand Etc
graphic uses this to draw a distinction
between the Statesmen and the soldiers
one group posing for paintings and the
other doing all the killing Graphics
sees himself as a wartime leader who
does the Dirty Work himself and the cafe
gravity gives multiple heavy pores of
sugar and water calling back him using
three sugar cubes in episode one this
Sweet Tooth defies his preference for
scroll food products in this Cafe we see
the gallery also has an exhibit the
faces of Freedom including figures like
Winston Churchill we also see William
Cavendish who helped the British win the
Seven Years War and on the far right
Duke Wellington who led some victories
in the Napoleonic Wars graphic believes
that these leaders don't really deserve
any credit even though ones like
Wellington totally got their hands dirty
the surrounding people reveal themselves
as skrulls and they shape-shift into
gravic so much for home and my own skin
rather than reveal their green skin they
pose as their leader suggesting that
they are more of a cult than a nation of
many I also noticed that when this
girl's transform their clothes transform
too but not the backpacks purses and
jackets hanging off the chairs so our
scroll shifted clothes part of the
squirrel flesh or do squirrels have
special clothes that can also transform
with them remember in episode 1 Gaia
promised Beto that they quote wear
scroll skins which I think is their term
for whatever scroll clothing we saw them
wear in Captain Marvel as they arrived
on the beach and it's just that some
Scrolls on the run like Beto had to
adopt discarded human clothes and
constantly swap outfits or just stay
stuck in one human identity so anytime
we see squirrels transform and their
clothes transform too I think we are
seeing that special clothing that can
shift along with their flesh meanwhile
backpacks purses jackets that they
aren't currently wearing you know the
kind of stuff that Airlines make you
stuff underneath the seat in front of
you are just additional accessories that
the Scrolls carry around as props have I
thought about this harder than people
make the show probably secret invasion
is great for when you've got the itch
for subtlety and subterfuge but when
your sense of fantasy leans more toward
Epic Fantasy war then you're gonna want
magic The Gatherings universe is beyond
set the Lord of the Rings Tales of
Middle Earth available now the Lord of
the Rings Tales of Middle Earth is an
absolutely epic introduction of your
favorite characters stories and settings
from the genre defining fantasy novels
directly into magic the gathering's
trading card game if you're somebody who
knows the Lord of the Rings books by
heart you're already a leg up on the
competition by knowing which characters
pair well together the mechanics of the
game and the lore of the books go hand
in hand and if you're like me and love
running what-if scenarios you can build
out your decks to set up showdowns
between Aragorn and Gandalf Sam wise and
Sauron whoever you want the Lord of the
Rings Tales of Middle Earth is the
biggest magic released so far this year
by highlighting iconic characters
stories and settings Magic the Gathering
offers a new and rewarding experience
for current and new players to enjoy to
get started with the Lord of the Rings
Tales of Middle Earth just click the
link in the description below Taylor
says you don't understand the first
thing about humans they're at their most
formidable
when they're threatened by a common
thought yes gravic believes that a core
human trait is just this act of evil
murder but what Talos understands is
that human violence is not rooted in
evil it's rooted in something you could
say is a bit more dangerous fear of the
other Talus is implied that the Avengers
coming together to repel Loki and then
Thanos and historically For All Mankind
that other is an invasive presence
another Nation another religion or
another ethnic group so graphic thinks
that humans are just evil Taos is like
no it's xenophobia Talos says your
Rebels will be put down like the rabid
dogs you are yes gravic again lichen
with canine imagery after he said that
he liked dogs back in episode 2 Talos
stabs Graphics hand graphic ugh slides
his hand off the knife but he heals it
using extremist Tech this is something
that the extremist soldiers had in Iron
Man 3 showing that he has already become
a super scroll and trailer shows that
graphic will also have Groot limb
extension Powers so will all the super
squirrels have all four of the powers
that we saw on the screen or some
combination of powers outside an old man
bumps into Talos to give him this phone
this is definitely Gaia having handed
off the phone that she wrote the Neptune
info into and we see this man hurrying
across the street and on the other side
of the white van suddenly we see Gaia
leaning against the car but notice that
same old man is on a phone call on the
sidewalk behind Gaia so Gaia cleverly
used the form of a nearby pedestrian
that she used to cover her tracks
assuming graphic would be watching her
Fury meets Talos in a pub I got a lead
or a rebel scroll was high up in here
it's in London right now you know we
never actually saw Fury receive any
intel like this unless he's referring to
hearing Rhodey on Priscilla's phone
Furious behavior is just really odd in
the scene he seems unaware of his past
fight with Talos he calls that
traditional English breakfast dog food
when earlier we saw Fury make it
essentially the same breakfast with
poached eggs and tomatoes Fury in this
scene is no longer wearing his glasses
maybe reaching by pointing out when Fury
is and isn't wearing the glasses but we
may be seeing two different Furies and
the fury we see here is a skrull who is
playing Talos either one working for
graphic because this whole submarine
plot is really just sting operation by
graphic anyway or someone on another
front of this scroll invasion they call
Sonya fallsworth who has found Furious
contact lens and debugged the owl statue
with she says it was previously named
hoot now she is named it Nicholas Fury
and she gives it an high patch maybe out
of paranoia that there could be some
other sensor Tech remaining on that
owl's eye Sonia found a leak in her
ranks a man with his Red Beard this
actor is Tony Curran who plays Vincent
van Gogh in the episode of Doctor Who
Vincent and the doctor we actually saw
this guy briefly in a scene in episode
one where Sonia met with that MI6 agent
which is seen by Fury through his office
bug clear to indicating that Sonya is
dealing with problems of her own Fury
and Talos discuss why humans clean up
dog poop another instance of a
hierarchical relationship between humans
and dogs and the fact that Talus doesn't
get why humans would love dogs so much
as to pick up their droppings it's just
another aspect of humankind that Scrolls
don't fully understand we can love a
species so much even more than our
fellow humans that other
extraterrestrials would just see us
beneath us it's the complexities of
human empathy that no other
extraterrestrial can fully understand
sometimes it is hypocritical sometimes
it's inconsistent but it's human also
worth noting that skrulls hate cats as
we saw in Captain Marvel because cats
resemble flirtkins Tales takes credit
for Fury successes saying he anointing
other squirrels working as his invisible
spy Network fed him the Intel he used to
ascend the ranks of Shield specifically
the Bogota crisis when Fury rescued
Alexander Pierce's daughter was
apparently thanks to skrulls and those
same Scrolls might have been part of
gravic's terrorist Network that recently
attacked Bogota so we learned that the
origins of Fury's era of Shield was all
baked in with scroll influence therefore
it's even more likely that one of the
Avengers Roadie is scroll but I don't
think it's just Roadie I think someone
else from phase one might have been a
scroll is it a little weird to have Ben
mendelsohn Tell Samuel L Jackson that
everything great about his character in
the MCU came from him one episode after
Jackson and Don Cheadle had a great
scene about black men having to work
hard to wrestle power of a mediocre
Whiteman yeah it's kind of weird I would
have preferred if this line was spoken
to Fury by his wife Priscilla it just
would have been more impactful Talos
poses as Bob and infiltrates the home
can we have five of Fury
don't ever change maybe Taylor's
greatest fear is that Fury might have
been corrupted as a scroll little does
Taylor Snow the fury he's been talking
to May still up in this girl again I'm
getting to it at the end of the video
Fury guns down each guard correctly
assuming that if Bob was swapped as a
scroll so much members of his household
security staff Taylor's radius to Fury
come in Taylor
sorry Nick I was
always ah to which Fury later responds
nobody calls me Nick yes Fury is using
the rule established back in the 2019
Captain Marvel film everybody calls me
fury not Nicholas not Joseph not Nick
just Fury excellent work Nicholas and of
course over the years many and MCU
characters are called Fury Nick Tony
Stark called him Nick Murray Hill and
the infinity War post credit scene
column Nick and that was before she was
turned into Soren and that doesn't make
those characters Scrolls but it is
something that has been true between
Fury and Talos and Talos either set it
here to tip off Fury that he had a gun
to his head or maybe the Bob scroll
replicated Taylor's voice and said Nick
into the radio Fury responds by holding
a gun to Zachary Bob's son the
negotiation seems to work on scroll Bob
which is interesting because Bob is a
scroll so either Zachary is a squirrel
too or squirrel Bob has spent so much
time in this human form that he has
formed an emotional attachment to his
human son just an interesting little
detail that's showing these Scrolls when
they are taking these identities are
also weighed down by the human emotions
those identities come with Talus
eventually shoots the scroll Bob in the
chest when he insults him about Gaia
Talus calls Gaia and Gaia without
hesitating breaks into the fracking pod
room and we see the human Chris Stearns
the human Pam Lawton in a human form of
commodore Fairbanks Fairbanks is wearing
his dress uniform suggesting he was
kidnapped from an important event I am a
little worried about all these humans in
a radioactive hotspot there even flesh
is not mew235 resistant it's just I
wouldn't keep these people in this plant
for that long they're all gonna come out
of this with cancer we see how this
girl's fracking pods contain the human's
memories allowing them to scrub through
it reminding us of the fracking pod
Carol Danvers was in and the First Act
of Captain Marvel among these memories
we see Fairbanks helping Zachary put on
a watch fly fishing a soccer ball being
kicked swimming with Zachary looks like
maybe they're in an argument at one
point Zachary watching a soccer match on
TV and cheering the memory effect is
pretty cool looking it's kind of like
looking through water and puddles like
the Pin C than Harry Potter these
emotional core memories explain why
scroll Bob feels emotions for his fake
son and fury used that to exploit Bob we
also see how Dr Lawton is one of the
humans in the fracking pod and behind
her there is a personal color who some
are saying looks like James Rhodes but
to me that doesn't really look like Don
Cheadle so Taylor sees is a code word
sakuri to abort the launch and again
assuming this is all Graphics planned
out Gaia did Talos really just sacrifice
three of his scroll operators Pagan
xerxu and Beto as well as this girl
posing as Fairbanks and all of his
security men just to expose Gaia while
knocking a better eye on her so that she
could go off and get super scroll
abilities I don't know what's going on
here but yeah when graphic shoots Gaia
outside the guard booth we do not see
her fully bleed out and die on the
ground and I think it's because we saw
her on the previous Leon in that super
scroll chamber I think she has extremist
healing powers he's in trailers we've
seen Gaia in a ton of scenes that have
not yet happened on the series including
one shot of her glowing in an energy
field but I do think graphic intended
this hit to be something like the hit on
Sonny Corleone and The Godfather because
that guard booth is empty just like the
toll booth guy Ducks down beneath the
guard booth before Sonny gets shot I
think this all tells Gaia that something
is off but either way guy ain't dead
we're gonna see her again the episode
ends with Priscilla who retrieves the
bank's Security box key and takes the
train to the bank where she gets a gun
and takes a phone call St James Church
one hour
I need to speak to graphic yeah well
you're talking to me whoa this is 100
Don cheadle's voice Cheadle is credited
in the episode both in the opening and
the closing credits and in the German
dubbing the actor used for the voice is
the same voice actor who always voices
Don Cheadle so this would confirm that
James Rhodes war machine at least the
one we've seen on the show the one who
fired Fury the one who refused to
empathize with Barry in episode 2 is
currently a scroll or at least someone
in graphics chain of command the
question now becomes how long has Rodi
been a scroll the reasons I discussed in
last week's breakdown I would be very
surprised if the MCU were to establish
that the Roadie we saw during Avengers
end game was a scroll I also think that
the conversations between Brody and Sam
Wilson and the Falcon the Winter Soldier
which is too grounded in their shared
histories as men of color working for a
country that doesn't care about them
would be far less impactful if that
Roadie was a squirrel culturally
appropriating the unique black
experience in America it would just be
controversial for a number of reasons
for this series to save the squirrel
immigrant
well awful and oppressing is equal to
the black experience in America they
ain't equal I just don't think Marvel
Studios would go there okay so
ultimately for now I'm gonna say Brody
was taken recently for the love of God
please let it be recent but our
Priscilla and scroll Roadie working
against Yuri are they on team graphic or
are they working to protect him here's
the theory I'll leave you with I think
we may be seeing a game of double
spycraft here and I think there are two
Furies in the field one Fury working the
graphics side of the field talking to
people like Priscilla and Rhodey wearing
glasses to see what's really going on
with them but another Fury working
alongside Talos one who doesn't need
glasses to know what's going on inside
talos's heart could that second theory
be Soren Taylor's wife that would
explain why this Fury's interaction with
Talos have been that of an old married
couple and why Furious looks so
emotional after several moments with
Talos I don't know I think it's still
possible that Soren's just dead but I
want to know your thoughts on this
Theory a huge thanks to our team of
writers and researchers you know it Chan
Eric Francisco Gina ipolito and Jordan
Morris for their help with this
breakdown subscribe to all three of our
channels new rock stars break room in
the Deep dive and support us by grabbing
some merch at nerd riot.shop follow me
on Instagram and Twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars thanks for watching bye
[Music]